j'ouvre tout de suite notre second débat
il est donc consacré le porte sur la
famine dans la Corne de l'Afrique qui
subit sa pire sécheresse depuis 40 ans
je pourrais résumer la situation avec la
brutalité d'un chiffre 36 une personne
meurt de faim toutes les 36 secondes en
Éthiopie au Kenya et en Somalie le mois
dernier l'UNICEF l'Oxfam l'action contre
la fin équerre lançait l'alerte
qu'est-ce qui a été fait depuis comment
les guerres vous en parliez comment le
réchauffement climatique aggrave la
situation avant d'en débattre le constat
d'une des pires catastrophes
humanitaires de l'histoire avec Cécile
Sixou
dans ces camps de fortune des milliers
de Somaliens ont trouvé refuge premier
touché par le réchauffement climatique
il fuit la sécheresse l'absence depuis
leur a fait perdre leur récolte et leur
bétail ils sont menacés de famine
bien que la Somalie ne contribue
pratiquement pas au changement
climatique les Somaliens en sont parmi
les plus grandes victimes
près de 5 millions de personnes
connaissent des niveaux élevés
d'insécurité alimentaire et bien sûr la
hausse des prix aggravent la situation
Somalie Éthiopie Kenya Soudan dont la
Corne de l'Afrique une personne meurt de
faim toutes les 36 secondes et au total
dans cette région 22 millions de
personnes sont menacées de famine même
constat au Sahel ou 18 millions de
personnes sont en situation d'insécurité
alimentaire outre le réchauffement
climatique les conflits armés ont
aggravé la situation mais aussi le
manque de dents res alimentaires liés à
la guerre en Ukraine la communauté
internationale tire la sonnette d'alarme
et appelle à l'aide humanitaire les
ressources dont dispose l'OMS et ses
partenaires pour répondre à la crise
sont insuffisantes pour faire face à
l'explosion des besoins la Somalie et
ses voisins de la Corne de l'Afrique
ainsi que les pays de la région du Sahel
ont besoin de l'aide du monde entier et
ils en ont besoin maintenant
la générosité des donateurs ne permet
plus de compenser la croissance rapide
des besoins en Somalie il manque un
tiers des 6 millions d'euros nécessaires
réclamés par les Nations unies pour
faire face à la crise
on explique les raisons de cette famille
historique avec Jean-François Riffaud
bonsoir bienvenue vous êtes le directeur
général d'action contre la fin Sylvie
mateli bonsoir bienvenue à vous aussi
économise directrice adjointe de
l'Institut de relation internationale et
stratégique et vous publiez ce livre
géopolitique de l'économie 40 fiches
illustrées pour comprendre le monde
s'est aux éditions eyrol j'accueille
Mathieu brun bonsoir bienvenue vous êtes
chercheur directeur scientifique de la
Fondation pour l'agriculture et la
ruralité dans le monde également avec
nous en duplex en visioconférence Sylvie
Brunel géographe professeur de
géographie à Sorbonne université bonsoir
vous publiez nourrir livre aux éditions
bûcher Chassel et je signale vous étiez
également l'ancienne payante d'action
contre la fin et Mathieu croissanto est
resté à mes côtés évidemment je vais
donner un chiffre pour démarrer
Jean-François Riffault selon le
programme alimentaire mondial 22
millions de personnes menacées par la
famille cette année sont des chiffres de
de janvier
5 mois plus tard qu'est-ce qu'on peut
dire de la situation dans cette dans
cette partie là 45 mois plus tard 45
millions menacés menacés par la famine
la famine c'est le degré extrême
d'un sécurité alimentaire mais si on
élargit un petit peu la proche un humain
sur dix ne mange pas à sa fin un humain
sur 10 puis de 830 millions de personnes
sur terre ne mangent pas à leur faim ce
chiffre a augmenté de quasiment 20% au
cours des 10-12 dernières années
et
on connaît les processus qui amènent à
cette situation là ils sont connus ils
sont documentés il y a de la science
posée sur l'ensemble de ces processus et
de ses causes là qu'il s'agisse des
conflits qu'il s'agisse du changement
climatique qui s'agit des inégalités
sociales et économiques qu'il s'agit des
enjeux de genre aussi on connaît les
causes d'un des pires drames
humanitaires qu'on n'a jamais connu et
on continue à pas regardé cela alors il
y en a un certain nombre qui se battent
il y en a un salon qui se battent sur le
terrain des acteurs humanitaires et au
premier chef les personnes concernées et
les ONG locales mais il est temps que un
vrai mouvement politique se met en place
que l'ensemble des personnes qui se
sentent concernées par ça pas uniquement
les politiques mais les personnes qui se
sentent concernées par ça décident que
on applique les solutions qui existent
et qui sont sur notre disposition et on
évoquait la question d'un gouvernement
mondial dans à la fin du premier débat
j'ai volontairement fait la transition
évidemment entre les deux thèmes
cinématelli est-ce qu'on en est loin sur
ces questions on a des lois sur toutes
les questions j'aurais pu dire ça
j'aurais pu dire ça effectivement mais
sur la question de la fin dans le monde
et des familles très très loin et ne
serait-ce que des initiatives moi je me
souviens de 2008 la crise de 2008 avec
des spéculateurs qui sont mis en cause
parce qu'ils spéculent sur les marchés
des matières premières et Nicolas
Sarkozy qui dans le cadre du G20 propose
de créer un groupe de travail pour réf
réfléchir à la façon de réguler cette
spéculation alors il y a je crois que
l'Autorité des marchés financiers en
France à prix des dispositions pour
encadrer la spéculation sur ces marchés
il y a eu des initiatives aussi au
niveau européen mais on est quand même
très très loin d'avoir réguler ces
marchés or l'une des raisons pour
compléter la liste des causes de famille
que vous avez cité c'est aussi le jeu de
certains acteurs financiers qui eux ne
meurent pas du tout de faim et ils font
beaucoup beaucoup d'argent sur la
spéculation sur ces marchés si on reste
sur le constat Mathieu bien brun qui
sont les premières victimes de ces
crises alimentaires sont les plus
fragiles parmi les fragiles les femmes
les enfants effectivement ce sont les
les plus fragiles parmi les fragiles
vous l'avez bien rappelé la première des
des causes de l'insécurité alimentaire
et de ses grandes famines c'est les
conflits ce sont les conflits les
guerres les crises qui touchent en
premier les plus les plus vulnérables
donc on est bien sur des couches de la
population qui n'ont pas les moyens
économiques sinon logistiques d'accéder
à leur alimentation au quotidien donc ce
sont les femmes ce sont les enfants ce
sont les personnes qui sont en situation
de handicap ce sont les personnes qui
sont exclues des sociétés et qui n'ont
pas accès à des politiques de protection
sociale de protection des plus des plus
vulnérables
complémentaire qui que je trouve encore
plus dramatique c'est que 70 à 80% des
personnes qui luttent contre la faim
sont des paysans
ce sont des personnes qui non seulement
sont censées cultiver pour nourrir les
autres et dont on imagine que d'abord
elle se cultive pour se nourrir
elle-même 70 à 80% des personnes qui
luttent contre la faim sont des
personnes qui se sont censées nourrir
les autres alors ça s'explique aussi et
ça dit en complément de la longue liste
ne cause que nous avons souligné sa dit
aussi le dysfonctionnement profond du
système agro-industriel agroalimentaire
mondial et le besoin on pourra en parler
peut-être tout à l'heure le besoin d'une
souveraineté alimentaire un peu plus
affirmée pour que les premières
personnes qui sont au premier en premier
lieu
censé produire pour les autres et bien
arrive au moins à produire pour
elle-même alors là on a évoqué on va
dire les les causes ont peut-être
structurelles Sylvie Brunel je viens
vers vous parce que malheureusement la
corde de l'Afrique moi de depuis des
décennies voilà j'ai l'impression de
d'entendre parler de de famine et de et
de malnutrition dans cette partie du
monde donc il y a les causes endémiques
les causes structurelles si je vous pose
une question sur les causes
structurelles parce qu'on va essayer de
les détailler un peu ensemble ensuite
vous diriez quoi Sylvie Brunel
sur les causes plus conjoncturelles
vous avez tout à fait raison Thomas
Hugues les chrysalimentaires
sont extrêmement récurrentes dans la
Corne de l'Afrique depuis un demi-siècle
mais ce qui est marquant c'est que leur
fréquence s'accélèrent pourquoi parce
que les écosystèmes se dégradent parce
que les populations sont extrêmement
pauvres chacune des personnes présentes
sur le plateau à énoncer des causes qui
sont très justes il faut bien comprendre
que la malnutrition chronique c'est lié
à la pauvreté c'est lié au problème de
pouvoir d'achat mais quand ce greffe
là-dessus des conflits qui vont toucher
des minorités des minorités
périphériques des minorités négligées et
bien on va arriver un phénomène
extrêmement aigu qui est la famine la
famine si l'on peut agir si les ONG
peuvent intervenir si elles peuvent
apporter de la nourriture on arrive à
l'enrayer le problème c'est que la
famine touche précisément des régions
qui sont en guerre et on peut pas mettre
du tout sur le même point les quatre
pays que vous avez cités voyez par
exemple le Kenya le Kenya c'est un pays
qui devrait pouvoir nourrir sa
population sauf que ceux qui souffrent
de la fin au Kenya se sont justement des
pasteurs somalies dans des régions
périphériques en Somalie on a un
problème d'affrontement entre des clans
en Éthiopie on a ce problème de la
guerre avec le Tigré mais on a aussi le
problème de la minorité Somalie en
nogaden et puis le Soudan est d'ailleurs
votre carte n'était pas tout à fait
juste parce que le Soudan aujourd'hui ce
sont deux pays soudant du Nord Soudan du
Sud ou Soudan honneur vous le savez il y
a en ce moment à la guerre une véritable
guerre avec énormément de migration et
où Soudan du Sud qui devrait être le
pays des rivières qui est un pays
extrêmement fertile et bien les
populations sont dans une pauvreté
insigne et ne cesse de s'affronter
depuis l'indépendance du Soudan du Sud
c'est à dire depuis 2011 alors justement
ce vous parliez du Soudan je propose un
premier témoignage dans ce débat celui
de la directrice du programme
alimentaire mondial pour le Soudan du
Sud elle parle en quelque sorte de le
terme est pas très bien choisi de ma
part mais je veux dire comme ça d'un
empilement des crises écoutez
cette crise ne pouvait pas arriver à un
pire moment au Sud Soudan nous entrons
dans la saison des pluies la circulation
est extrêmement difficile nous comptons
déjà 7 millions 400 000 personnes ayant
besoin d'une aide alimentaire nous ne
sommes pas en mesure de les nourrir
toutes en raison des problèmes de
ressources nous avons également du
réduire nos programmes à cause du manque
de moyens financiers et maintenant nous
devons à nouveau redéfinir les priorités
entre les personnes affamées et ces
nouveaux arrivants qui sont extrêmement
vulnérables
Jean-Paul rifault Jean-François il faut
pardon quand je parle de d'empilement
des crises si on prend des cartes elle
se superposent c'est ça la carte des
guerres les cartes de la famille les
c'est un constat terrible et qui et qui
se multiplie ce que je veux dire par là
c'est que vous prenez la la carte des
conflits et vous regardez que la carte
de la fin se superpose à quasiment 90%
en d'autres termes 90% des personnes qui
luttent contre la fin sont dans des
endroits où il y a la guerre pays
concret région etc mais si vous prenez
aussi la carte des plus grandes
injustices sociales et économiques de
l'AB totale d'accès aux soins de
l'absence totale d'accès à l'éducation
cette carte se superpose aussi assez
facilement avec avec la carte de la fin
on pourrait certainement faire la même
chose avec la carte de l'impact
climatique du changement climatique sur
les pays les plus fragiles je rajoute un
dernier élément sur les acteurs
humanitaires c'est que ce qui est
terrible aussi c'est que la carte des
incidents mettant en cause la vie des
acteurs humanitaires ce superposent
aussi elles strictement avec la carte
des conflits et donc avec la carte de la
fin et donc on a une forme de cercle
vicieux ou de plus il y a de plus en
plus de nombres de personnes à prendre
en charge et accompagner et c'est de
plus en plus difficile de le faire vous
restez présent dans ces dans ces pays
malgré malgré la guerre oui parce que
sinon vous pouvez pas
action contre la fin comme une dizaine
d'autres grandes zones internationales
nous sommes encore présents vaille que
vaille en Afghanistan c'est tout dire
donc nous sommes encore aussi présent au
Yémen nous sommes présents au Burkina
malgré la dégradation
délirante de la situation dans pays nous
sommes présents Soudan nous sommes
présents aussi de Soudan vous prenez les
pays qui sont en guerre et bien vous
trouverez action contre la fin et
d'autres ONG et d'autres ONG
internationales présents dans les pires
endroits de ces pays-là Mathieu brun
vous dites que la fin est une arme
politique qu'est-ce que ça veut dire oui
parce que là on a l'impression que
finalement c'est cette insécurité ces
problèmes logistiques ces difficultés
d'accéder sur le plan logistique à
l'alimentation qui cause l'insécurité
alimentaire mais à l'inverse on peut
retourner cette arme qui est la fin
contre les populations notre histoire et
malheureusement jalonnée de moments où
des hommes et des femmes ont utilisé la
privation de nourriture la famine comme
Marme politique stratégique depuis les
Égyptiens les Grecs ou les ou les
Romains jusqu'à Bachar el-Assad ou même
l'état islamique également et
aujourd'hui c'est volody myersky qui
brandissait cette arme alimentaire que
la Russie avait tendance à à utiliser
pour son propre pouvoir pour sa propre
diplomatie en l'utilisant la force
qu'elle a c'est à dire sa puissance
agricole le blé pour pouvoir et bien
augmenter son son sa diplomatie
augmenter son ses capacités aussi
d'influence à travers la planète et donc
ce sont toutes ces armes politiques qui
sont d'ailleurs interdites par le droit
international humanitaire il y a une
forme de gouvernance aussi de ces
éléments-là qui posent aussi problème
parce que on avait tendance à mettre ça
derrière nous mais c'est vraiment une
actualité très forte interdire empêcher
les récoltes de circuler empêcher
l'accès au semences polluer les sols
polluer on pense à la Seconde Guerre
mondiale mais c'est encore un quotidien
malheureusement très important et et
extrêmement dévastateur pour la fin dans
le monde on se posait la question de la
responsabilité ou de la capacité
d'action des pays riches des pays
occidentaux simulatellit mais dans un
contexte comme celui-là comment on peut
inverser la inverser la tendance c'est
pas vous voyez il y a aussi une part de
responsabilité on l'évoque là des des
pays concernés et voilà ça limite la
capacité d'action des États occidentaux
oui ou non
alors c'est intéressant parce que vous
parlez en même temps d'une urgence la
situation qui est dramatique et il faut
arriver à quotidiennement à aller
nourrir ces populations et en même temps
de tendance et c'est vrai que et on sait
peut-être plus que jamais que le
changement climatique l'instabilité qui
en découle et tout des facteurs que nous
avons cités vont faire que les crises
aujourd'hui se cumulent et que la fin
dans le monde et massivement de retour
et ça ça va durer ça va durer quelques
années donc ça c'est un élément très
important face à ça
alors il y a l'urgence et l'action dans
l'urgence c'est l'action des ONG et
c'est ce qu'elles essayent de faire mais
c'est vrai que comme ça va durer des
années au-delà de l'urgence il faut
effectivement penser des stratégies qui
vont permettre de réduire je vais pas
dire solutionner parce qu'il y a
probablement pas de solutions mais de
réduire ces risques et là pour le coup
je serai pas pas très optimiste regardez
depuis combien d'années les pays les
plus riches comme vous les avez appelé
snob évite d'aller à la conférence
annuelle de la FAO donc l'Organisation
des Nations Unies pour l'agriculture et
et l'alimentation on n'est pas concerné
quoi c'est le message que ça renvoie
alors même que financièrement les
besoins sont pas comparés aux dépenses
que l'on peut engager en période de
covid et autres les besoins financiers
sont pas si énormes et ça c'est très
inquiétant et et moi je ferais bien le
lien vous l'aviez fait tout à l'heure
avec votre plateau précédent la
conséquence la conséquence de ça c'est
quand même le réfugiés climatiques
est-ce que dans les programmes de nos
hommes politiques aujourd'hui ne
serait-ce que dans ce pays il y a prise
en compte dans même dans les programmes
de de sur l'immigration et le contrôle
de l'immigration est-ce que cette
question de la fin dans le monde et ne
serait-ce que citer absolument pas c'est
pas un sujet souvent considéré sous
l'angle du co-développement mais au sens
large mais jamais la fin moi ce qui me
frappe c'est que vous l'avez dit les
sommes en jeu quand on
donc c'est colossal j'entends là j'étais
sur l'urgence mais oui bien sûr à long
terme bien sûr tout le monde peut en
profiter il existe aussi des dynamiques
qui sont en oeuvre alors effectivement
ils sont peut-être pas à la hauteur des
enjeux mais au sein du comité à la
sécurité alimentaire mondiale il y a des
discussions il y a des régulations qui
sont pas obligatoires il y a des
relations qui sont volontaires il y a
des directives il y a des normes donc il
y a une forme de gouvernance mondiale de
la sécurité alimentaire mon voisin de
gauche pour en témoigner beaucoup mieux
que moi qui malheureusement est encore
un peu molle est encore un peu trop soft
et qui n'a pas vraiment d'action sur sur
le terrain mais elle existe par contre
effectivement on a quand même des méga
des mécanismes qui sont liés à la
régulation des marchés qu'on connaît à
chaque crise alimentaire vous allez
entendre les mêmes experts qui vont vous
dire on pourrait faire ça on pourrait
agir là-dessus on pourrait agir sur les
stocks de réserve on pourrait agir sur
l'utilisation de ces céréales le maïs et
d'autres qu'on utilise pour la
production d'énergie donc on aurait des
mécanismes d'action simplement il y a
des barrières à l'OMC et ailleurs qui
empêchent d'agirl oui parce qu'il y a
pas de pénurie les choses de la planète
on pourrait nourrir tout le monde on
produit assez d'alimentation en plus
la même question il y a effectivement
enfin bon on produit plus que ce qu'on
ne ce dont on a besoin sur la planète
c'est ça
alors pendant longtemps on n'a pas
produit assez il a fallu mener des
révolutions vertes pour augmenter le
niveau des disponibilités alimentaires
mondiales aujourd'hui on produit
suffisamment c'est ce qu'on appelle les
disponibilités le problème c'est qu'il y
a un certain nombre de population qui
n'ont pas accès à la nourriture soit
parce qu'elles sont trop pauvres c'est
un problème de pouvoir d'achat vous avez
par exemple le cas de l'Inde qui est à
la fois un très grand pays producteur de
nourriture et qui compte en même temps
250 millions de personnes qui souffrent
de la fin et puis vous avez un problème
d'accessibilité des populations par les
ONG Jean-François Riffaud par exemple
l'action contre la Faim est très
présente et essaie de faire de son mieux
pour atteindre les populations au Yémen
ou ailleurs qui sont qui souffrent de la
faim mais elles ne sont pas accessibles
donc cette question d'accessibilité à la
fois aux populations et des populations
à un pouvoir d'achat qui le peint leur
permet d'avoir accès à la nourriture et
bien c'est là que le bât blesse alors en
même temps c'était pas une fatalité
insurmontable même avec le changement
climatique même avec la dégradation des
écosystèmes chaque fois qu'un pays en
fait une priorité et bien on observe des
résultats très rapides et par exemple on
parle de cette corde de l'Afrique on
parle du sel mais si vous regardez ce
qui se passe dans cette partie
obscidentale du sel et bien vous avez la
Grande muraille verte qui arrive
justement à renforcer les disponibilités
alimentaires mais ce sont des actions
structurelles et les ONG et bien elle
joue un Rolex extrêmement important
quand elles peuvent justement appuyer
avec leurs compétences et leurs capacité
d'aller dans ces endroits difficiles
pour renforcer les compétences
structurelles alors que ça soit femme
avec Mathieu brun que ce soit action
contre la fin avec Jean-François
Riffault elles sont extrêmement
nécessaires et utiles mais globalement
il faut de bonnes politiques agricoles
alors on va merci beaucoup on revient
vers vous et bien évidemment tout à
l'heure si vous voulez je vous pose à
Steve journal de nous rejoindre tout de
suite parce que je voudrais en parler
des aides à l'instant je voudrais
rebonsoir Steve que vous nous disiez ce
que ce que fait la France en matière de
lutte contre la famille dans le monde
bah elle donne de l'argent notamment
avec nos impôts au contribué en effet à
lutter contre la famille dans le monde
par l'intermédiaire de ce qu'on appelle
LED françaises au développement
l'objectif affiché de la FD ou APD c'est
très simple en tout cas sur le papier
les radications de la pauvreté c'est ce
qui a été encore rappelé dans une loi de
2021 vaste programme Emmanuel Macron il
y a quelques semaines et revenu sur les
efforts de la France en la matière
écoutez la France est aujourd'hui
solidaire nous sommes même devenus le
quatrième pays au monde pourvoyeur
d'aide
nous avons investi 15 milliards d'euros
dans notre solidarité internationale en
2022 là où nous investissions 10
milliards d'euros en 2017 donc vous
voyez la progression en 5 ans on a
vérifié la française au développement
c'est effectivement aujourd'hui plus de
15 milliards d'euros ça représente 7,8 %
de l'aide mondiale consacré au
développement alors dans cette aide
qu'est-ce qui est spécifiquement
consacré à la lutte contre la famine et
vous avez raison la de développement
comporte beaucoup de programmes qui
visent plein de secteurs différents un
climat environnement égalité femme homme
éducation en ce qui concerne la lutte
contre la fin il faut savoir que la
France a mis en place une stratégie dite
internationale très concrètement pour
les situations d'urgence ces situations
de famine un fond d'un peu plus de 140
millions d'euros existent aujourd'hui ça
s'appelle l'aide alimentaire programmé
la moitié de ses fonds sont destinés à
des pays prioritaires quelles sont ces
pays les pays d'Afrique en grande
majorité l'année dernière 66% de l'aide
alimentaire programmée a été dirigée
vers le continent dans le détail tu te
rends compte qu'un quart des crédits a
été alloué au pays du Sahel et d'Afrique
de l'Ouest on retrouve ensuite par ordre
décroissant les pays du Moyen-Orient
d'Asie ou encore d'Amérique et des
Caraïbes selon le ministère des Affaires
étrangères l'aide françaises a permis au
total de financer 118 interventions en
2022 ça correspond à un soutien à porté
après de 5 millions et demi de personnes
à travers le monde merci beaucoup Steve
Jean-François
Riffault sur ses cet argent finalement
sur l'urgence tiens parce que on a
commencé le débat en disant que la
situation était en train de de
s'aggraver rapidement de s'aggraver
rapidement
cet argent il est disponible pour
d'abord pour l'urgence alimentaire oui
les 140 millions de l'aide publique
Madeleine alimentaire programmée elle
s'appelle comme ça au lycée ça fait
étrangère français et de l'argent pour
la réponse humanitaire donc pour de la
réponse d'urgence c'est une contribution
qui a nettement augmenté il faut rendre
hommage au gouvernement et à l'état ces
cinq dernières années qui a nettement
augmenté mais qui reste extrêmement loin
des standards internationaux les
Américains donnent 6 milliards les
Allemands donnent un milliard sur l'aide
alimentaire
et donc la question d'urgence a besoin
d'être financé mais et c'est ce que vous
entendiez aussi tout à l'heure je crois
que la question n'est pas que financière
on voit bien autant pour répondre à
l'urgence que pour répondre aux
problèmes de structurels que mentionnés
Sylvie Brunel a juste titre la question
elle est financière mais l'enveloppe
financière globale ne serait pas aussi
insupportable que cela on parle de
probablement quelques dizaines de
milliards ou quelques milliards de
dollars mais pourquoi ça ne marche pas
parce que ça ne suffit pas et donc je
vais le dire très clairement même si ça
peut paraître un petit peu paradoxal
qu'un dirigeant en ONG dise c'est pas
que l'argent qui
résoudra le problème moi je le dis ce
n'est pas que l'argent qui résonnera le
problème nous avons besoin d'argent mais
à nous n'arriverons pas à régler le
problème de la fin dans le monde soit
ces situations d'urgence soit même
l'accès à des situations durables pour
les populations s'il n'y a pas à côté
des investissements des meilleures
politiques des gouvernances nationales
des pays concernés plus responsables une
gouvernance internationale mieux
coordonnée et plus responsable aussi et
où la paix ne se n'est pas là lorsqu'il
n'y a pas l'API il y a une résolution à
laquelle vous y référence tout à l'heure
des Nations Unies qui interdit
d'utiliser l'arme de guerre la fin comme
une arme de guerre pardonnez-moi tout le
monde regarde ailleurs tout le monde
regarde ailleurs donc l'argent oui mais
encore une fois l'argent ne suffira pas
et je pense qu'on peut le trouver mais
il faut de la volonté politique autant
de la part des gouvernements nationaux
que d'un gouvernement un peu collectif
mais vous nous l'avez dit ça a été le
début de notre débat la carte des
guerres se superpose à celle de la
famille ces guerres elles sont
déclenchées voilà au sein même de ces
pays ou entre ou entre ces pays donc
quelle est la part le levier d'action de
ce qu'on en revient à ces solutions
qu'on cherche et si elles étaient
simples on les aurait déjà été la folie
des hommes quoi la cupidité et la folie
des hommes parce qu'on le voit bien et
vous le disiez tout à l'heure je veux
dire beaucoup en profiter de la guerre
en Ukraine vous savez là le les produits
alimentaires de premier nécessité
augmenter en moyenne de 20 % dans les
pays d'Afrique et du Sahel dans
lesquelles nous intervenons je veux dire
il y avait j'étais à Kaboul il y a trois
mois j'étais au Burkina Faso il y a un
an et en Centrafrique également donc je
suis juste après le début de la guerre
Ukraine il y avait de quoi manger dans
les étals des marchés il y a de quoi
manger sur les étals des marchés des
pays les plus pauvres mais en face il y
a des gens qui ont les poches vides donc
le question c'est où est passé cet
argent donc la cupidité et la folie des
hommes pardon mais c'est un sujet qui du
coup nous dépasse dépasse les ONG aussi
c'est le le contrôle du conflit le
contrôle de la relation conflictuelle et
peut-être aussi une petite lueur
d'espoir imaginez que à l'inverse la fin
en tout cas les conditions de sécurité
alimentaire lorsqu'elles sont réunies
contribuent à réduire la propension au
conflits
sur le les conséquences de la guerre
d'Ukraine vous avez déjà participé à
plusieurs débats là-dessus mais le mot
spéculation vous l'avez déjà employé
tout à l'heure mais en général comment
on peut la coller à ce qui se passe
depuis depuis un an et demi sur les
enjeux alimentaires comment on peut la
coller c'est à dire quelle est la part
de spéculation dans l'aggravation de la
situation de la famille en Afrique j'ai
mieux posé ma question je suis d'accord
avec beaucoup
la spéculation c'est quoi la spéculation
sont des acteurs financiers qui jouent
sur les marchés financiers à la hausse
ou à la baisse c'est à dire ils achètent
à bas prix pour revendre plus cher et
bien évidemment on sait que sur
l'ensemble des marchés des matières
premières j'ai pas le détail sur les la
différence entre les marchés agricoles
et les marchés de d'autres matières
premières on sait que
80% des échanges se font de gré à gré
donc il y a un peu plus de
95% des échanges qui se font sur les
marchés financiers mais par contre on
sait que ce sont ces marchés financiers
qui fixent les prix à la hausse comme à
la baisse et au moment de la guerre en
Ukraine il s'est passé quoi mais au
moment de la guerre en Ukraine vous avez
deux grandes puissances agricoles qui se
font la guerre là l'Ukraine qui est en
tout cas au tout début de la guerre et
de vous me direz de plus en plus depuis
le début de la guerre qui est fortement
touché ça veut dire des terres agricoles
qui sont fortement touchés par ce
conflit donc des acteurs financiers qui
anticipent que la production va être
mauvaise et qui anticipe la hausse qui
achètent tout de suite à bas prix en
anticipant la hausse mais le fait
d'acheter tout de suite à bas prix en
anticipant cette hausse vous savez les
marchés financiers c'est c'est le lieu
des anticipations auto-réalisatrices je
veux pas non plus vous faire un cours
d'économie ce serait malvenu mais c'est
important de le rappeler donc le fait de
parier sur une hausse quand vous créez
cette hausse vous augmentez les prix et
vous avez ces éléments là et je crois
qu'il y a un élément on parlait à
l'instant des conflits et de la paix il
y a un élément qui est très important à
souligner c'est que aujourd'hui les
Occident qui sont fortement intervenus
depuis une vingtaine d'années pour
essayer de pacifier un certain nombre de
pays bien suite au déboires en
Afghanistan au déboires français
également dans le Sahel ou ailleurs bah
on est plutôt dans une logique de repli
sur soi ce qui veut dire que les
tensions les conflits risquent de
s'aggraver on a des Nations Unies qui
sont quand même aujourd'hui sacrément
handicapés par un Conseil de sécurité ou
personne est d'accord avec rien et où
chaque membre permanent un droit de veto
donc on voit que outre les acteurs
financiers on a aussi cette difficulté
de gouvernance mondiale qui vient
amplifier les difficultés Sylvie Brunel
sur le les effets les conséquences de la
guerre agression russe en
Ukraine sur les marchés alimentaires et
sur donc leur impact sur la famine dans
cette partie de l'Afrique il y a pénurie
de certaines denrées et inflation les
deux les deux phénomènes se cumulent
c'est ce qu'on peut décrire
oui alors déjà pour revenir à cette
question de la spéculation il faut
comprendre que pour par exemple les
paysans africains souvent au moment où
ils ont leur récolte ils vont la brader
parce qu'ils ont absolument besoin
d'argent et il va y avoir tout un
ensemble d'intermédiaires qui vont leur
acheter à très bas prix et puis ils vont
se retrouver quelques mois plus tard
dans des situations de pénurie ce qu'on
appelle la soudure et là et bien le prix
de la nourriture flambe la guerre en
Ukraine et la guerre elle a eu pour
conséquence que un grand nombre de pays
d'Afrique avait pris l'habitude de
s'approvisionner en Ukraine et en Russie
parce que les prix étaient bas parce que
il y avait tout ce soft power de l'arme
alimentaire dont a parlé Matthieu brun
et on s'est retrouvé avec non seulement
une pénurie directe de nourriture
d'huile et de céréales mais on s'est
retrouvé aussi avec une pénurie de
fertilisant et ça c'est extrêmement
important parce que si vous produisez
une tonne de céréales à lecta et bien
vous comprenez que vous êtes beaucoup
plus vulnérable que si vous produisez
trois tonnes 4 tonnes 5 tonnes alors on
peut tout à fait travailler avec les
paysans pour leur permettre d'augmenter
leurs production d'augmenter le
rendement c'est ce que fait par exemple
la Fondation forme ou d'ailleurs Action
contre la Faim le problème c'est qu'on
peut pas agir sur l'ensemble de la
filière de commercialisation c'est à
dire que une fois qu'on a produit plus
le paysan se retrouve confronté à la
question de la commercialisation à la
question du transport de la conservation
des céréales à la question des marchés
et là la spéculation même la spéculation
du petit commerçant elle est extrêmement
active parce que quand on sait que la
nourriture manque bien on fait des
stocks les les commerçants font des
stocks et puis ça tendent que la
nourriture augmente pour pouvoir la
lâcher sur les marchés de façon beaucoup
plus comment dire au compte-goutte et le
rôle des gouvernements
et bien c'est justement d'être capable
de lutter contre cette spéculation de
lutter contre ces jeux en créant à la
fois des stops on en a parlé mais en
faisant aussi des distributions des
lâchages de nourriture sur le marché
c'est l'aide alimentaire qu'on appelle
structurel pour faire baisser les prix
donc ce que l'on comprend quand on
regarde la question de la fin c'est
qu'il faut agir à tous les niveaux la
production agricole la transformation la
distribution
l'interventionnisme public parce que si
vous laissez l'agriculture livrée aux
lois du marché vous êtes foutu et puis
bien sûr la question essentielle sur
laquelle on a beaucoup insisté mais qui
est vraiment vital qui est la paix sans
P de toute façon il y a toujours la fin
la paix et puis avec le changement
climatique la pluie et s'il n'y a pas la
pluie et bien les pluies c'est-à-dire la
possibilité de régulier l'accès à la
ressource en eau pendant toute l'année
parce que dans ces milieux qui sont des
milieux tropicaux vous avez une saison
des sèche une saison sèche et une saison
des pluies alors on reviendra à la
question du réchauffement climatique et
le lien entre entre les deux entre
famille et réchauffement mais j'ai
encore quelques questions sur la
question de sur ces sur les aides et la
façon dont elles sont utilisées moi
quand je pense à l'agriculture
européenne Mathieu brun elle est quand
même fortement subventionnée qu'est-ce
qu'on peut dire de l'agriculture
africaine en comparaison on peut dire
qu'elle est pas du tout très très peu du
tout très très très peu subventionner à
la Fondation forme on a sorti un
observatoire qui nous permet de comparer
en pourcentage de la valeur agricole les
soutiens publics les dépenses que l'État
fait pour soutenir son agriculture et sa
transformation alimentaire le constat
qu'on a attiré c'est que plus un pays
dépend de son agriculture notamment en
termes de de de population qui travaille
en agriculture d'économie vraiment
vivrières moi il la soutient plus un
pays dépend de son la culture moins il
la soutient si on a fait ces calculs qui
sont malheureusement dramatiques de
soutien par actif agricole on a comparé
un actif agricole américain aux
États-Unis un actif agricole au Ghana
l'acteur américain et 2700 fois plus
soutenu qu'un agriculteur au Ghana
comment est-ce qu'on peut dans ces
conditions-là être compétitif mais ne
serait-ce que arrivé à produire et
accéder à ces types de à ce type de
production si on regarde les subventions
qui sont les dépenses publiques qui sont
accordées notamment sur le continent
africain en Afrique subsaharienne
principalement c'est des subventions aux
intrants
en a parlé avec beaucoup de justice
justesse pardon dont des intrants des
semences mais aussi des intrants type
engrais produits phyto phytosanitaires
et bien ces produits là ont connu une
hausse vertigineuse depuis bien avant la
guerre en Ukraine quelques années
auparavant on voyait la hausse des prix
qui qui s'envolaient donc les
agriculteurs sont soumis à des hausses
de prix qui ne peuvent pas ensuite
répercuter sur sur le marché d'autant
plus et c'est des rapports de la FAO qui
le montrent bien que c'est 600 à 650
milliards d'aides annuels à
l'agriculture qui sont massivement
orientés vers les agricultures du Nord
participent pas à créer des modes de
production qui sont durables la semaine
dernière était en Côte d'Ivoire avec la
Fondation phare mais on a eu la chance
de rencontrer des producteurs de cacao
de maraîchage qui sont en agroécologie
qui limite au maximum l'utilisation d'un
train pourquoi parce qu'il dépend de
l'extérieur il y a pas de production ou
très peu de production d'un train de
synthèse sur le continent africain donc
il développe leur propre solution les
cacahuètes les cacahu cultures par
exemple la partie de la Cabos de cacao
qui est très riche pour faire des des
intrants et pour mettre de la matière
organique dans les sols ils ont
développé un ensemble de de techniques
de savoir pour essayer de ne pas trop
dépendre de l'extérieur et d'être
relativement souverain sur sur leur
production et c'est dispositifs qui sont
particulièrement innovants ne sont
absolument pas soutenus par les les
gouvernements
idem pour les semences
quelques textes sur ces questions de
semences aujourd'hui les les recherches
internationales sur les semences sont
concentrés sur des variétés sur des
types de culture qui sont très
importantes le riz le blé les céréales
le maïs mais les tubercules lignames le
TEF toutes ces céréales qui qui sont où
ces légumes qui sont hyper importantes
pour la sécurité alimentaire dans les
pays du sud elles sont pas du tout
soutenues et sont pas du tout
accompagnés en termes de recherche et
pour accéder à ces semences là c'est
aussi très compliqué donc il faut et
plus une semence elle est utilisée dans
le temps si la recherche variétale aussi
est très importante pour avoir des bons
des bons rendements donc ça demande
aussi de structurer une offre à ce
niveau-là Jean-François il faut sur ce
thème là il y a une double
responsabilité des gouvernements de ces
pays-là d'abord mais aussi d'une aide
occidentale qui pourrait être fléchée
vers justement une forme de subvention à
ces agricultures notamment et puis on va
commencer à aller vers la question du
réchauffement climatique pour que elle
ne dépendent plus d'un marché
international et qu'elle soit le plus
souveraine et le plus local oui ça vous
faites bien de rappeler je l'ai je l'ai
fait aussi un peu tout à l'heure parce
que c'est difficile à faire mais il faut
le dire d'abord la gouvernance locale
d'abord la responsabilité des états dans
lesquels nous sommes présents avec leur
accord bien entendu mais il faut il faut
le rappeler et puis ensuite en effet
mais je vais le traduire un un petit peu
différemment c'est la connexion entre le
financement de l'aide humanitaire et de
développement vous savez
souvent les les financements
internationaux qui viennent d'ailleurs
de en gros 12 grands pays occidentaux et
qui constitue le plus gros de l'aide au
développement et de l'aide d'humanitaire
sont fléchés selon deux grands types
d'enveloppes des enveloppes de
développement avec des modalités
spécifiques de décaissement et des
souvent des actions bilatérales et puis
les enveloppes humanitaires la réalité
sur le terrain c'est qu'une organisation
humanitaire comme action contre la fin
est aussi une organisation de
développement je m'explique nous
traitons et nous sauvons des enfants
sévèrement malnutri à Kaboul awagadougou
Abuja amaydouguri etc etc nous les
sauvons donc ça c'est de l'humanitaire
des enfants qui devaient mourir ne
meurent pas mais en parallèle on
travaille sur les causes de la fin et ce
que vous disiez Mathieu est très
intéressant parce que nous ça évoque ce
que nous faisons à Madagascar par
exemple ce que nous faisons aussi à hors
dans un une province d'Afghanistan nous
travaillons en amont pour apporter des
intrants de meilleure qualité pour
travailler sur des semences adaptées au
lieu et aux conditions pour apporter du
savoir technique aux populations aussi
et je me rappelle de paysans à rors
justement en Afghanistan au mois de
septembre dernier au moment de la
moisson qui était très content de la
moisson faite accompagnée par action
contre la faim on a eu du financement
là-dessus donc qui était très content
d'avoir plus de Blake que prévu mais qui
en revanche était très désespéré de voir
qu'il ne pouvait pas vendre son blé
puisqu'il y avait personne pour acheter
son blé et donc voilà le sujet c'est la
connexion à la fois entre une
gouvernance collective et une
gouvernance locale mais c'est aussi la
connexion entre le temps court et le
temps long je vous propose puisqu'on
parle de réchauffement d'écouter le
secrétaire général des Nations unies
Antonio gutheres qui était en visitant
en Somalie et qui se souvient de son
dernier séjour dans ce pays c'était en
2017 il fait la comparaison
la situation est alarmante encore une
fois le changement climatique est à
l'origine du chaos la Somalie a connu
cinq mauvaises saisons des pluies
consécutives et cette situation est sans
précédent
et demi de Somaliens devraient être
confrontés à des niveaux élevés
d'insécurité alimentaire aiguë le risque
de famine est toujours présent si Matéri
si on essaye de de calculer le coût des
catastrophes climatiques
là on parle de quoi de milliers de
milliards c'est on est dans quelle
échelle de grandeur et à quel point ça
ça frappe justement on est sur la
superposition des cartes ces pays les
plus pauvres l'estimation qui a été
faite pour 2022 et qui est une
estimation sur ce qu'on connaît qu'on a
pu mesurer donc qui est probablement
sous évalué c'est que les catastrophes
naturelles ont occasionné environ 2000
milliards de dommages à l'économie
mondiale en 2022 s'est en record mais
2000 milliards pour vous le remettre
dans le contexte c'est l'équivalent du
PIB de l'Italie mais c'est aussi
l'équivalent du PIB de l'Afrique
subsaharienne donc ça veut dire qu'on a
perdu à cause du climat et des
catastrophes naturelles enfin des
catastrophes climatiques pardon en 2022
l'équivalent de tout ce que produit en
termes de richesse l'Afrique sur
saharienne sans dit long sur et on est
qu'au début de ce phénomène sans
handicat même assez long sur les
conséquences que va avoir le changement
climatique sur ces populations déjà
extrêmement vulnérables Sylvie Brunel on
parlait de services tout à l'heure c'est
quoi sont des écosystèmes qui sont
fragilisés par le réchauffement et qui
donc enfin voilà on voit bien la baisse
de production qui s'ensuit comment ça se
passe en fait
et bien les familles
Talis les ONG connaissent très bien cela
c'est à dire qu'elles vont se séparer
petit à petit ben pour pouvoir à leurs
besoins qui sont des besoins de survie
d'éléments essentiels des outils et puis
progressivement elles vont devenir de
plus en plus vulnérables certaines
d'ailleurs vont partir elles vont migrer
vers les villes où elles vont migrer
vers les camps donc elles vont former
des populations déplacées qui pour le
coup dépendent totalement de l'aide
internationale pour survivre et
globalement ces populations elles sont
sur des écosystèmes qui se dégradent et
il a dégradation de ces écosystèmes fait
que chaque crise climatique et on a vu
que leur fréquence s'accélérer dans
l'accord de l'Afrique et bien chaque
crise climatique vient se surimposer sur
un territoire qui est de moins en moins
résilient de moins en moins résistants
avec des familles de plus en plus
pauvres c'est pour ça quand on est au
goût terrestre dit à juste titre j'ai
l'impression que la situation est de
plus en plus grave parce que là-dessus
se greffe bien sûr le croix
démographique plus on est pauvre plus on
a d'enfants et ces populations sont
aujourd'hui par rapport à la capacité de
charge des territoires sur lesquels elle
se trouve elles sont trop nombreuses
c'est à dire qu'il y a un phénomène de
type malthusien localisé avec un
déséquilibre entre les populations et
les ressources
Mathieu il y a aussi des absurdités
c'est à dire que des produits de denrées
alimentaires qui étaient produite dans
ces pays les plus pauvres et qui
finalement enfin qu'aujourd'hui ils
apportent vous voyez ce que je veux dire
parce que ils ont été écrabouillés par
alors c'est facile de dire ça mais par
voilà par le système
économique agro-industriel il faut dire
les mots c'est ça la démonstration
absolument en fait il y a on a des cas
de pays le Sénégal par exemple qui était
un grand producteur de riz et qui se
trouve aujourd'hui contraint d'importer
une grande partie de son risque c'est la
même chose au Nigeria en Côte d'Ivoire
et en ce sont des pays qui ont la
capacité de produire mais qui sont
écrasés par le marché par les prix
internationaux du marché de riz qui
vient par exemple d'Asie du Sud-Est qui
est beaucoup moins cher parce que ces
pays ont fait le pari d'investir
massivement de leur agriculture et
d'exporter massivement leur production
et ensuite de de d'inonder en fait ces
terres-là mais ça dépasse l'entendement
du riz qui vient de l'autre bout de la
planète peut être moins cher que le riz
produit dans dans juste à côté par
manque d'investissement par manque
d'accès aux agriculteurs et qui n'ont
pas accès aux fonciers qui n'ont pas
accès au semences de qualité qui n'ont
pas accès à des systèmes d'irrigation
qui n'ont pas accès à des marchés on
pourrait égrainer la liste moi j'ai du
mal à comprendre parce que là on parle
de pays où la main d'oeuvre on est n'est
pas cher qu'on est ce raisonnement en
France en disant bah oui la Mado est
tellement cher qu'on va chercher un
produit fabriqué en Asie d'accord mais
mais là la Madone n'est pas cher alors
la manœuvre est pas chère elle est
nombreuse mais c'est justement pas
qu'une question de de mandrun c'est une
question de voilà de volume
d'investissement dans les politiques
publiques et de consommation aussi
notons quand même que l'Afrique va
doubler sa population d'ici à 2050 et
puis vous avez aussi un dumping
volontaire ou un volontaire on parlait
tout à l'heure de la Russie qui vendait
son blé très peu cher à ces pays c'est
une arme c'est une c'est un instrument
d'influence donc elle a dont elle a
abusé et quand je parle de dumping à
volontaire en son temps on a et c'est
largement documenté et ça a été l'objet
d'ailleurs d'un certain nombre de de
mouvements paysans y compris dans nos
pays les politiques agricoles en Europe
et aux États-Unis
poussaient soutenez fortement la
production et faisait chuter les prix
sur les marchés internationaux donc
quand vous avez sur le marché la
possibilité d'acheter un poulet bien
moins cher que de le produire vous-même
il y a pas photo vous achetez le poulet
vous dites que vous ferez autre chose
pour gagner votre vie sauf qu'à un
moment donné vous vous rendez dépendant
et là aussi les questions d'autonomie et
de souveraineté pour autant très vite
pour autant on peut inverser les
tendances à la Fondation femme on a pu
bien article sur le la filière poulet au
Sénégal ils ont mis un une règle qui
interdisait d'importer du poulet
d'Europe ils ont développé leur secteur
de volailles et donc là on voit qu'en
fait en agissant sur de la régulation
internationale ça pose plein d'autres
problèmes à lire la publication on peut
on peut inverser cette tendance pareil
maïs au Rwanda et et voilà ben voilà on
termine sur une note sur une note un peu
plus optimiste merci beaucoup merci à
tous d'avoir participé à ce débat qui
était vraiment passionnant cinématisé au
politique de l'économie 40 figillées
pour comprendre le monde c'est donc aux
éditions et puis Sylvie Brunel merci à
vous aussi et je rappelle le titre de
votre livre nourrir c'est aux éditions
bûchet Chastel belle soirée à toutes et
à tous merci Mathieu d'avoir participé à
cette émission comme tous les lundis et
mercredi je vous dis à demain 18h 22h
sur Public Sénat vous pouvez aussi
retrouver nos programmes cette émission
et tous les autres programmes de la
chaîne en replay sur notre plateforme
Public Sénat point fr